Yeah, I thought it was...
That's what it was asking me to do.
If I copy the last message and just put it in a text editor, are you asking?
Okay, I'm seeing some of the messages.
The very first message where you said hello in Russian,
it's toggling the Russian part on and off and then show edit history.
I don't know if we've edited any messages, have we?
Okay, yes, I see the edit updates.
No, when I change the transcriptions to expanded or collapsed or hidden, it doesn't seem to change anything, no.
Yeah, I see the document.
Text file, I load it, it comes up with the instructions.
Seems to be working.
Be link.
Okay, I've just tried to, I'm not sure if that's shown up on your end.
On my end, it's just a blank message.
Gonna post the link.
Yeah, I can still see the document when I post the link into a separate tab.
Okay, so now I do get the message, this XML file does not appear to have any style information associated with it, the document tree is shown below, with an error saying code, no such key, the specified key does not exist, so I do not have access to it anymore.
Субтитры создавал DimaTorzok